just i've been watching a lot of youtube
shorts and i just lose my mind watching
this stuff why are you watching
it pops up when i watch them some of
them are funny something pretty good but
obviously just all reposts yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like there's some there's
like some genre videos that i just think
i absolutely despise to death and uh one
of them is like this is genre i don't
understand it at all
oh this is video and there's this guy
right and there's like imagine that your
phone is vertical whatever it's cut into
two
there'll be one video of the guy
explaining the video that is about to
play before you
okay that is very self-explanatory right
right so there's one where there was
this video and he was like this guy's
like here are the different types of
pokemon compared to each other in size
and because like pikachu one meter
snorlax one
whale and it's like i did not need you
to tell me what this is and i don't need
you to sit there for ten seconds like
this
while the video is playing after you've
explained oh he's still on screen he's
still on screen the whole time he's just
sitting there he's like and then he'll
go like whoa that's big well i didn't
expect that pokemon to be big and it's
like what is this what is this you saw
someone else's video you reposted it oh
it's not even his video no and no no
it's no of course it's not his video and
just repost it and it's like this is
[ __ ] this is the worst type of content i
hate this so much it's literally just
stealing i just hate it man yeah it's
terrible i hate reaction reactions 2.0
the evolution this is what it because
yeah that's what it is instead of like
it's reaction videos with somehow less
they've made reaction videos that are
somehow worse than reaction yeah where
they're like not even reacting it's like
hey i'm going to explain to you what the
video is going to explain to you
they're literally just a talking
description box yeah it's that's all it
is actually i i immediately skipped them
whenever or any like financial advice
ones i skip immediately there's a lot of
those there's a lot of ones that start
off with inspirational music you'll be
scrolling but you'll hear the
inspirational music here's how i made my
first million dollars
sir why are you working for ten dollars
an hour and it's like i know this is
going and it's like i work for one
thousand dollars an hour you know why i
value my time and it's oh my [ __ ] god
this is the the sheer amount of guru
stuff yeah tick tock and and youtube
shorts is insane it's way out of control
well yeah i mean like it's it's all kids
you're gonna think that like everyone
should be earning 10 grand a minute you
know what i mean like they're like
they go back to their dads you know and
their kids like what do you want to do
for christmas or what do you want to do
with the rest of your life kid comes in
with a [ __ ] bluetooth headset dad
i've already started making 10 000 an
hour from dropshipping online you know
the fact that you're working at your job
is actually kind of cringed at
you know what i mean it's like
like you're gonna have a whole
generation of kids race like this tragic
they're in like [ __ ] kindergartens
like putting down what they want to be
when they grow up everyone puts
entrepreneur
entrepreneurs that's like what do you
want for christmas son dad why haven't
you invested in my 401k this is
embarrassing
when you grow up where would you like to
go silicon valley
it's the only destination it's [ __ ]
absurd
it's so stupid man
i can't stand this just do what you want
man just do what you want there's a lot
of really funny stuff there on there but
you have to you've just siphoned and
shoveled through so much [ __ ] yeah to
find some good tick tocks that's why i
just wait for them to eventually get
onto twitter yeah yeah
you know if they like like make their
way on like youtube compilations or
twitter which is how i consume most my
tick tock because i did i i did actually
try downloading tick tock uh the other
day and i gave it a go and i was just
like
oh it's just
i i'm i'm i don't have enough patience
for the algorithm to find what i've
really liked because there's so much
[ __ ] you go through and there's like
it's so weird seeing some of the tick
tocks that are there because i remember
i remember i remember going through
animatic talk right and seeing okay i'm
i am i am an anime youtuber i trade i
wonder what animatic talk right is uh is
up to that was your first mistake
asking that question so so there was
this like really really weird trend that
was going on which is like the
silhouette trend or something like that
right i remember that [ __ ] okay okay so
you know you know you know what i'm
talking about
well like where like these girls or guys
would like basically
pretend that they were making out with a
silhouette of a character or something
right yeah and one of them's funny
i'm one not really but it's just like
it's 100 series it's ironic oh it's
ironically funny oh i thought i thought
i thought it was a jerk no no no no no
no no it's a hundred percent it's funny
for us to joke i thought it was a joke
it's a hundred percent serious that
where like we're like well like you just
pretend like you're making out with
someone right and it's like there's no
irony to it it is just
it is just that yeah and i remember i
was browsing anime tick tock and i saw a
clip which had like millions and
millions of views on this clip and it's
this and then there's this girl who's
pretending to make up with a silhouette
of bark ago and they literally look they
literally put in sound clips of the dub
to make it seem like he's like uh he's
in a he's in a dominating fashion
for this tick tock and i'm just like
i must be getting old because i remember
i remember if you did this like when i
was an anime fan growing up you'd get
bullied for this you would get chris you
would like this like this is the type of
[ __ ] pretty good people got internet
bullied for man i like the jojo post
wrong it's like jojo jojo was cool that
one was cool that was cool because it
was like yeah because like there was
either people who were just really good
at jojo posting but then there were
other people who like took that and put
like a spin on it right with like all
sorts of different anime and stuff
that's fine but like that [ __ ] is the
same as like you know like laughing at
those is the same as people you know
laughing like back in the day of like
you know watching people proposing at
anime cons and stuff like that right
like those like that trend of video it's
just like kind of coming back but now
it's just on tick tock now yeah and it's
it's just so weird seeing these things
trending and being popular because i
just remember thinking
wow like this is
so much different to being an anime fan
when i was [ __ ] yeah when i was like
they just like post anime scenes and
like play different music yeah and i'm
like what is this what i don't watch
this [ __ ]
i've seen this repost of this one anime
scene a million times and it's some
samurai versus like a lumberjack
and they're like fighting each other
okay i i've seen this scene reposted on
youtube and tick tock and stuff like a
million times i don't know what it's
from all right but i've seen this fight
like a million times and it's just
always on tick tock i don't get it is it
like good at all yeah it's pretty cool
okay that's it
they just keep reposting it like i don't
get it
at least it's not like the samurai
lumberjack making out right in the
silhouette challenge
it could be next t-stock idea
it gave me the same reaction as you know
the that animation of like sonic and
mario making i love that actually
it's it's that one has like so many
layers to it though there's no fiery
passion at which
uh mario and sonic are making out and
sonic rips off mario's like
shirt and like such a passion yeah yeah
that makes me feel like they are in love
it's so fun it's amazing
god yeah just i don't know man like i
tried downloading tick tock because like
users ticked off quite a bit we sound
like boomers here okay i'm trying to get
understanding i tried it i tried to just
can't do because i saw it was getting so
big so i was like all right well then
you know if it because it is getting so
big there might be a chance one of these
days i might have to start using it
right yeah i i scrolled through it i
just feel like i'm losing my mind yeah
right i feel like my mind is going numb
watching this stuff because it's so
fast-paced you don't get a chance to do
anything you don't just like think you
just all right next next it's just it's
like literally just constantly just
watching instagram stories yeah yeah i'm
like i can't do it i never felt so much
information i was in like a black mirror
thing until i was watching youtube
shorts right yeah and tick tock because
like
you don't even like you're not even
watching the videos you're just like
consuming the videos yeah yeah you score
the next one scroll the next one you
don't even think you just scroll keep
scrolling you don't and like on youtube
at least you have that thing of like
well i'm going to look what i want to
watch now this isn't the good okay
page all right refresh the homepage look
at the brow you know you have to
actually think what you're about to
watch yeah but on tick tock and shorts
they just feed it to you yeah and you
don't think it's weird right like i feel
like we're getting to the point where
content is being forced down your throat
it's like not what you're choosing to
watch right right i mean there's this
there's so much there's some content on
tick tock which was just so
weird because it's like it was almost
like hypnotic because there was some
there's some content that it's just like
had obviously like millions and millions
of views and it's just like some very
oddly satisfying thing or something or
something i don't know it's it's so hard
to describe why
i was like
not invested but just like
intrigued by it yeah but it's i wouldn't
call it like interesting content it was
just like oh that's a entrenched could
take your
a bit that's that's a bit interesting
all right and next oh oh okay that's
that's pretty good right
it wasn't like i was never like
emotionally invested in any of this
content which is why i kind of felt like
almost hypnotic in a way because it
doesn't give you the time to get
emotionally invested right because it's
over in six seconds yeah i mean i've
like i've the only funny tick tocks i've
seen i've been tick tocks that have just
like made its way into twitter or
youtube compliments yeah yeah like on
tick tock i don't know what i'm doing
wrong well how how do i how do you tic
talk how do i make tick tock good i want
to know i want to know where to find a
good content because you can't search
like you can't search for anything like
you can but you have to sift through
just like if you look up like a hashtag
right that if you happen to find one or
like an audio file or something that you
thought was kind of funny that's been
used right like you can search for that
but in order to find like the actual
gucci you just have to sift through so
much unrelated [ __ ] i had like a few
audios of mine like get pretty big yeah
yeah like from my youtube videos i was
just like what the [ __ ] is this because
it was like really bizarre things like
one where it was about me like saying
sucking dick or something yeah and
cosplaying and it like there's so many
people who used it to make tick tocks i
was so confused because it was like he's
like 13 year old kids being like there's
no time to talk i need to wear cosplay
and suck dick or something and i'm like
is this okay
what is going on i'm so confused
and i was like okay uh hopefully people
don't watch my videos uh because some of
these kids look really young
it's yeah i've had a couple of things
yeah i've had a couple of tick tocks
where they've used my audio i like it
though i think it's interesting it's
it's really cool because it's like oh
that's you know that's kind of
flattering that they thought it was
funny though i feel like i think i said
look at it i'm like yeah what's going on
but yeah but at the same time i'm like
that's cool but at the same time i look
at i'm like why are you doing this
well i i just thought i was thinking i
was like surely i've said other things
in in an order that are more
entertaining and more useful than that
like of all the things i've said you
thought this one was yeah yeah
i mean that's how the internet is right
it just takes things off i don't know i
don't know it's weird we don't we don't
know how to take talk yeah have you ever
have you ever like legitimately thought
being like i need to start a tic toc
[Music]
i mean i i'd like because there's lots
of youtubers right now who are like
i'm not convinced the tick tock audience
is
well the demographic i want right i
don't know i like the demographic i have
right now yeah i like just chill and do
mine things streaming games i mean it's
it's like i think we've grown up uh
we've brought we've like made an
audience that like us for us luckily
enough and like the content we make i
don't feel like i need to move myself on
a different platform just because that
platform is getting popular right it's
kind of like yeah we've definitely grown
with that well our audience has grown
with us yeah it's kind of like why i i
get so many messages about this about
god why don't you use instagram why
don't why don't you post more on
instagram
it's the simple answer of i just i'm
[ __ ] at taking photos okay i just forget
to document my life i'm sorry
okay and it's just you know i'm
that's why i get my girlfriend to take
photos of me because i'm so [ __ ] at
taking photos of myself
and it's just like you know you get
brands coming to be like oh instagram's
the you know instagram for most viewers
and the most like audience and the
biggest numbers and i'm just like well
is that really valuable just going on a
platform just because it's got big
numbers and the big audience or is it
like
as a content creator i find it's way
more valuable even if you're promoting
to a smaller audience that it's an
audience that is more suitable for the
stuff that you're making right right so
i'm not going to make a tick tock just
because it's popular unless i think i
actually like take talk well i think i
can make good tick tocks because
otherwise i'm going to get a bunch of
audience that i don't understand or yeah
and then go on and then and then i will
literally be the boomer then yeah you
know just like oh let's let's connect
with the kids everyone's having a tick
tock nowadays let's make my tick tock of
me making out with barca girl
maybe i would take off
maybe i could do it making out with